I'm a gentleman I'm not gonna kiss it -
Mike Johnson says he doesn't kiss and
tell but when it comes to his
relationship with the demi lovato he
definitely does I might not be a
gentleman are always it isn't nothing
anymore as it seems the pair's romance
is clearly heating up he's on a date you
got on one day we're gonna motor one day
okay and she kisses really well the 31
year old bachelorette fan favorite was a
guest on Ben Higgins and Ashley I can
Nettie's almost famous podcast where he
opened up about the confidence singer
admitting Demi was the one who initially
reached out to him for one I'm all about
her too and uh she definitely was the
aggressor you know I find it incredibly
sexy I love that light come at me you
want me come at me if I want you to come
at you and I'm coming at her as well
your personality death attracts me
according to Mike the romance blossomed
after demi gushed over him after his
relationship with Hannah Brown came to
an end on season 15 of The Bachelorette
now with the Air Force vet says he's
learning to adjust to dating someone in
the public eye and has nothing but
praise for the 27 year old singer she's
been in this light and that's why I said
she's so humble and I think the world of
her because I she's been able to have to
deal with this crap like for I can't
imagine from her perspective
Mike says he's looking forward to the
future and getting to know Demi on a
deeper level she's a woman that I treat
like a regular individual I'm a man and
she treats like a regular man and we do
like each other we are getting to know
each other I'm focused on it they hear